just want to let you all know right now
I know there's been a lot of messages
because there was a lot of concern okay
you were like are you guys okay burning
man I know you're stuck in the mud is
everything okay is everybody safe is
everybody have enough food does
everybody have enough water and the
answer to all that is yes because we
were in the Hamptons where they have
almost no mud and they have tons of
water and tons of food any regrets for
not being at Burning Man we know that
you have none you guys I think this
might be the most fun year I think so
Akash has a bunch of regrets
come on son if there was one year this
is the year I should have gone there was
one this is how you know God don't want
me a burning man because he took me out
the one year I would have liked it
doesn't count as cheating in your
culture when you guys the ground yeah
because we love it so much you know what
I mean but that does count as cheating I
have to it's not the [__] it's the
passion with which we do it I mean look
at that and try to not beat your